all right so now I have I have 12
pending challenges so let's play some
more people can i name any lines that
are as fun as a tracks later against
low-rated players the Stafford gambit
so much fun alright let's play let's
just play this guy first one to
challenge me board training looks okay
right
speaking of Stafford gambits maybe I'll
play it if he takes on e5 will he take a
lot of people will play Knight c3 he's
thinking okay Knight c3 so we're not
gonna get this saturated will have a
fortnight's I enjoy playing this against
lower rated players
83 he's playing like me any three is uh
usually what I like to play as white
because it's Bishop c5 there's Knight
takes d5 so I think what I'll do is play
a reverse Halloween gambit because a3
and the Halloween gambit shouldn't be
too useful and now
okay I'm stacking a piece for a pawn
Center
not the most sound opening but it is a
fun opening comparable to the Traxler
lock sacrifices early yet some
initiative I think this is most
effective if white were to play g3
instead of a three
because I'm the knight one have access
to g3 Knight c3 I don't think is a best
move but maybe it's playable so I can
play this and this line is now kicked
only save square is G 1 and this is
usually the point if one wants to save a
knight yes to undeveloped and then I can
just continue developing do I have
enemies I don't know if I have enemies
well I'm willing to play them if I do
the stream title is what is it playing
viewers enemies and something else and
subscribers all right let's play Bishop
c5 what's normal
I'm on the castle and White is being
materialistic which maybe it'll pay off
but hopefully it won't like now okay
white is long ways away from castling
and I'm a short ways away from castling
and I just want to attack f2 very soon
f3 this guy clearly does not listen to
Ben Feingold I mean the first impression
is taking Queen h4 and when H 2 so
Bishop takes G 1 row ticks g1 Queen h4
g3 takes h2 or @ g2 point h1 and then
I'm threatening Bishop h3 you could take
Bishop h3 work f2 mmm
G or I could play Queen h4 first but
then g3 I'm tempted just a castle here
gather up to Yates because I don't
really want to give away my bishop even
if I'm winning a pawn if I Castle he
takes twice on e4 I have to point h4 93
or 88 92 if Bishop e2 maybe Queen d4 and
I have to choose a target let's just
castle this is more of an intuitive move
I could calculate a lot but I think just
just preparing it this simple of rook e8
should be offering back a lot of
resources
okay so Bishop e2 so I still have the
possibility of taking in Queen h4 and
winning the pawn still have Ricky eight
still very tempted to play Ricki gate
let's play Ricki is more intuition yeah
what is a theory on the Traxler
I feel like like gets some slight
advantage in the line with Bishop takes
off seven and like this should be three
but I don't really know it's not really
knowing I studied for either side
Julian Pro Lake oh and the chats he's a
theoretician so it probably knows better
than me oh can I just take the pawn I
could on Toussaint but don't know if
that leads to anything let's just take
with the night you know I mean
dominating the center I'm still down a
piece but it doesn't feel like it okay
it takes probably just take back with
pawn unless there's anything better
Queen h4 g3 well let's just take or do I
thinking about Queen f6 looks
interesting
I'll take first its Bishop e3 I haven't
I take C to winning the bishop meanwhile
this Knight has issues dat developing
and even if the knight could develop and
White Castle there'd still be my bishop
so he's playing Bishop III this might
actually be the best move I know three
looks tempting to Knight take c2 is
simpler 9 f3
he takes with the pawn of Queen h4 that
looks really fun if he takes with bishop
I just take with pawn if he takes with
night I take with pawn takes I take mmm
Knight f3
oh wait I'm allowing some Queen trade
though and I don't want to Queen trade
okay so let's take on c2 now this Bishop
is nice preventing him from castling
also my queen is preventing him from
castling so casting would be extra
illegal and I think the threat is just
something like Queen f6 where it's very
hard to stop we enough to like rook do
you wan we probably make me very happy
Rick do you won Queen f6 he has Knight
takes e4 but I think I can just take
back just f2 is a made threat the night
h3 I just take it with my vision okay so
he takes on e4 right away Queen h4
forces Knight g3 there might be some
forcing line here like Queen h4 93
Bishop takes g1 or takes g1 Queen takes
h2 hitting these juicy pieces and I'm
probably winning a piece back but he
does have King f2 so maybe I'm not
winning a piece back I mean I hope dish
about 5 here looks attractive
Fripp do you while I can just take the
night it should be three I could take
with rook and play Queen h4 let's play
Bishop f5
when in doubt develop and I have a
little bit of hair bishops are so strong
and it's a pin and Queen h4 is still on
the horizon yeah if I were why that
would be terrified which is probably why
they call this Halloween gambit like
this is very terrifying if you hold on
to material like this okay so I was
looking ever it takes key for this ship
takes me for Queen h4 shouldn't be good
enough because if g3 I take and then
when she win the rook anything better
let's just do this - do you need - I
should have something actually if Bishop
takes e4 Queen h4 Keaney - I have Queen
f2 King d1 and rook - Yates and I'm just
meeting or even Queen f1 mate
immediately so this is nice
I'm forbidden to play the Halloween
gambits
if it's not Halloween no one told me
that it's time for some foreign drink I
don't know what these letters mean I
don't even know what language this is
maybe Japanese and eat Japanese people
in the chat oh this is green tea and you
realize has an English side - ah that's
sweet as expecting no sweetness maybe
it's not Japanese a lot Japanese people
don't make green tea sweets it's like
against the law or something well
d 4 looks really enticing there's
probably multiple ways to win this
let's just play rip d 4 so I'm pinning
the bishop and it's attacked three times
a is n chess my opponent Mouse slipped
she says now slip but whatever it's lost
anyway I wonder if he meant to play King
here I would still be lost probably I
think take-backs work but only on like
the the move that was just played
now if King e to give me to it actually
make me think maybe I would just play
Bishop g4 and then move the rook back
that's looks very fun and blacks not
even down a piece of kini - mmm so now
can you - no no I take the bishop and
win the Queen life is good
I am victor is half Japanese that's
enough
all right so he plays on I'll have to
made somehow rook d2 is probably the
first and foremost threat I still play
with d2 if Knight takes Queen takes if
King takes here Queen d3 King up for it
takes g2 I'm just gonna move the bishop
back Bishop will be useful in creating
some mating nets now the threat is rook
III probably the crook III oh it's even
better here because the king is forced
away like two if F 1 then I win the rook
if F 2 there's some discovery maybe now
in four takes f3 yeah and then Queen f6
I'll bring my other rook in life is good
wow what a centralized King but where's
the mate
let's just keep checking until it's meet
I just
to be careful about packing meats but
okay this is just about over ready to
take on b2 alright it's interesting game
III and four nights yeah it's
interesting but whatever white does in
this position there's there's aggressive
ways to play for black this was a bit
more extreme but okay at Bishop c4 or
there's taking what else
if g3 there's taking if there should be
five that's a bit more symmetrical but
then there's aggressive ways to play
later
alright so know if there's much to talk
about neck pain so let's play another
game Howard pawn with the usual 100 bits
thanks coward lon okay so there's a lot
of people now I think it's time for Siri
27 pending challenges give me a random
number between one and twenty seven
nineteen oh I don't want to count though
I just took someone in the vicinity of
nineteen let's play the last to know
okay last to know good luck before is he
here easier 29 f3
which I want to play let's play another
Halloween gambit if he plays Knight f6
I'm just taking menu 5 fun opening if he
doesn't play Knight f6 I guess he can
develop the bishop it's 4:00 a.m. where
you are Hawaii maybe where is it 4 a.m.
or no it's oh it's just California right
probably California okay I'm taking on
e5 we have another Halloween yeah that's
great opening la okay
so now the question is is he gonna save
the night or will he give it back
somehow mm-hmm saves it advanced forward
hey mr. white wabbits thanks for the Sun
something at 4:00 a.m. it's 717 p.m. in
Chiang Mai decently normal time so very
similar position to the previous game
except the previous game the night was
on c6 rather than g6 but it's still
pretty similar I'm okay if he takes my
nights because I'm my bishop can develop
and with the night on g6 it opened up
the possibility of for f5 so I'm
actually very tempted just to play f4
right away
I'm also tempted to play 94 leaving the
bishop a bit awkward
a little bit undecisive here because
both options look really nice
meaning towards the floor because i-5
just needs to so much fun and if 90 40
is d5 and I would have to take and his
Bishop comes back to life yeah let's
play out for so I'm realizing I probably
need a better system for handling the
challenges and it would be great if
there is some kind of like app or
website with like a queue or like a wait
list I'll have to I know off to do some
research so he still plays d5 good move
I don't think I want to take unless I do
want to take if I take I keep initiative
the bishop can come back but then I know
if I fight he just takes so maybe Bishop
d3 preparing f5 then he plays Bishop f5
but then I played g4 okay let's go for
this this is a faster game so I should
probably manage my time and I'll try and
prioritize subscriber challenges over at
any challenges at least so if you're a
subscriber and you want to play let me
know your user name in the chat probably
ask again after this game Patrick jmt
says I donated $100 other day I think
only I should get to play well I already
played you but if you have another game
I'd be happy to play you again look I
have to take still threatening a5 I've
the bishop here Bishop can come to life
my rook can come to life g4
is Nathan here Nathan usually pays me to
play g4 but here I don't need to be
tuned incentivized
because f5 coming next these pawns are
immaculate
yeah I like play I'd like playing people
who are really materialistic will go out
of their way so I just save material
because I'm it's fun to just keep
kicking them around it's like soccer
like wherever the knight moves I keep
kicking like s4 I could play f6 next
taking this night it's all about just
keeping initiative and improving while
making threats if I drop the Knights
like Bishop g5 I think just chop some
Knights
yeah no way to defend other Knights
pinned
I'm taking on five doesn't really help
so I'll win back the piece and I'll have
my immaculate pawn structure intact at
six I don't think helps either my
opponent is expressing his frustration
in chat
all right every night if g5 I just take
on purse lumps
not sure what my threat is I mean maybe
just to play off six actually there's
some funny line f6 Knight moves and then
I take attacking the rook threatening to
Queen and also attacking the Queen after
a six-night g6 I could also take here I
just take the Knights pinned so if he
takes back I can take here now the King
has to go to d7 I would like to meet
somehow Bishop f5 king c6 maybe Rick f7
is the simplest and then the knight is
pinned in two directions
yeah good enough and black is about to
flag feel a little bit bad for my
opponent but it's what happens took the
peace earlier you deserve to get
punished and now there's gonna be some
brutal mates came here get the rook into
play my opponent says it has been an
honor
nice game was a fun game just as fun as
the last one
yeah four or five I think maybe a better
try was Bishop f5 that way if I play G
for it me sirs taking but it's still
hard to stop I five from coming yeah
okay I was fun for me and not my
opponent that's true okay so if you're a
subscriber let me know your Lee chest
username if you want to play and if you
argue sent me a challenge subscribers
have their like unique subscriber badges
if there's no subscribers and I'll just
play someone random my subscriber i ce
o--'s n chess okay
let's plays n chess where's n chess was
in chess where are you keep people oh
there he is okay
oh he's 2115 highest-rated opponent so
far and we're playing casual rapid 6+3
imagining another halloween candidates
is this gonna happen he's playing g3 I
wonder if he's playing this cuz I
already mentioned this line we have a
third Halloween gambit in a row this is
another reverse Halloween gambit but
this has actually improved compared to
the last two because G 3 restricts my G
393 is usually the best move in this
line I believe pushing to remember where
is it
d4 it's t4
I recorded the series of videos for a
course like a month or two ago I was
showing this variation I think it's D
for D for a followed by like f5
it gets very sharp though an idea is if
the night doesn't move to e4 and moves
somewhere else I want to play e4
everything moves before I play f5 and
life is good
okay so II for I have some vague memory
of like seeing this
maybe this exact position in some like
high-level tournament back when I was a
young kid it was like taking place
onboard onion and black just completely
destroyed his opponent so again my
opponents being materialistic how to
punish him d3 is a move does he wants to
play d3 himself if d3 takes takes and
queenie to check so he probably won't
take and d3 9f for maybe g5 d3 there's
Knight c3 then there's 94 ideas
oh there's even like before I do think
t3 93 94 z3 that seems wrong
but oh I don't see anything concretely
wrong with it
let's play it if there's something wrong
with it I'll learn something but there's
a few ideas first idea if he takes a
night take Queenie seven is very hard to
stop if he moves his night than Queenie
seven wins back material the other idea
if he moves his night the night before
is pretty much guaranteeing night c2 a
night c2 like almost mates that came
like he would have to give up his queen
so one of the main lines I calculated it
was nice III night b4 takes takes Queen
a4 check but then I just had Bishop d7
night c2 it would still be coming so I'm
very curious what white is gonna do here
even if he's watching the stream and
he's listening to use lines I don't
think it's so easy to like stop all
these threats how are you memorizing so
much lines god it's not about memorizing
it's about internalizing ideas while
lions I just I don't have stuck in my
memory but I understand different types
of positions sometimes I do just have
memorized I'm assuming whites going to
give back a piece so if I want to I
could play Queen d7 I mean night before
it's still it's attractive I think he
probably has to take on d3 thinking
Queen e7 what is he gonna do 27 Bishop
e2
night before he probably takes we trade
Queenie to check and it's some slightly
better endgame at Queen e7 but at least
maybe he'll think he's play this he has
to block on you too
it's a benefit of having a pawn in d3
this move
well now ninety-four looks incredibly
attracted a Knight d4 I'm threatening
you mate and I'm threatening night C -
oh here's Queen a4 though mmm
I could have been a problem that could
have been a big problem so I've nike5 he
has Bishop g2
I mean I'm tempted just to play Bishop
g4 here Knight takes D 3 to be a little
bit careful
it's Queen a 4 is a useful resource
maybe I'll play might be for those white
is pretty much stuck night before if
Queen a for Bishop d7 Bishop g2 night C
- King F 1 I take them when the rook
let's do this if he takes on g3 I'm a
them okay you won't do that
so Bishop g2 okay so I'm winning the
rook I'll probably end up being up the
exchange I could take on you two first
oh but then he takes with night so let's
check take the knight and then win the
rook I'm going from being down the piece
to being up a rook that's nice
I'll probably lose my Knights but it's
gonna take time from to win the night
and then he'll still be down in the
exchange Atilla terzo that name sounds
really familiar other extremer right
streaming also instructive things on
chess comm probably more instructive
things than me
welcome to the chat alright so life is
good Halloween yeah but it's not an
opening that I played so consistently
but these games have been inspirational
for me
d4 so wanting to develop the bishop and
win the Knights I'm considering Bishop
f5 even Bishop g4 let's play Bishop g4
if it takes on g7 we can trade on you -
oh it's coin egg for a check so that
could be annoying there's a V for Queen
a for it but then I have Bishop d7 okay
my first priority is watching out for
counterplay
I'm aware of time there's three second
increments and we're getting close to
the point where if white isn't getting
any immediate conversation it shouldn't
be too difficult to win sb7 needs some
defending c6 I guess
like why gather up to you on it would be
more annoying thankfully is king is a
bit stuck on f1 and my night is safe for
the time being there's a tough four so
Queen before looks attractive Queen
before I mean if we Queen trade I
basically just win if Queen d3 then I'll
just complete development don't even
take on b2 we can see one I forgot about
I mean if he wants to go to a one with
the Queen
I'll let them do settle go play this if
you play as a three I can take and
counter-attack the Queen
I need a clock emotes I have a few more
emote like what you call them slots so
if people have emote suggestions let me
know let's play this and then I'll
castle and the night will be a target
the King is tied down to the thing the
knight and the Knights pinned and the
roots will come to Yates shortly maybe
my bishop will come to g4
yeah it's one of the issues when I
stream and play sometimes I just forgot
about time but time is uh it's not too
difficult here especially with all the
bullet and hyperbola chests I've been
playing recently minute in 14 seconds is
more than enough I want to see how I
would play if I was white now if I was
white I would be crying just looks so
sad
the Queen's on anyone the Knights pinned
rooks out of the play bishops aren't
doing anything
this should h3 looks attractive rookie
eights coming next
wow there's a funny tactic if Bishop g2
I have Queens e5 double pin genie one
makes me happy
now the threat might be fancy like take
Sandro cure but then there's Bishop III
so maybe my threat is even fancier
Bishop g2
feein cuddling my bishop in White's
territory mushrooms you two could still
work it's not mating let's do it
oh but there's Knight c3 ah but then I
take with check okay if he takes on g2
then I'll take the night and went F to
fancy move removing the garden
it's kind of the Queen on a one's just
gonna be stuck now I'm attacking the
bishop and winning d4
32 coming soon maybe you look to you to
figure out I have a extra rook queen bee
one okay
layer of d2 if Queen c2 I play Bishop to
b4 and now the bishops pinned and
attacked three times
there's rook do you want and probably
rip d8 it's using everything people were
telling me to use a red arrows to make
the thumbnails extra spicy okay he
resigns that was a nice finish okay
another another Halloween gambit in the
bag